To protect him from witches, and his first act as king was to have the Potion Master brew this, but before one sip could touch his lips, the witch's dust had cursed him, and we all know his unfortuitous end.
Please, envy and enjoy the protection from the magical makers in this neighborhood.
Oh, they just won the presentation.
I heard no mention of making that spot.
I know.
Oh, that's good.
Yes, it was great.
Non-witchy.
I sense some lavender here, which was not on the table.
Where did you get this lavender, Fred?
I don't know over there.
I do not believe it was specified in the rules that we were limited to ingredients on the table.
Very, very impressive foraging capabilities.
I commend you.
It was hand-smoked by the potion makers.
Oh, very light.
It tastes of moonlight.
And should we test the healing properties while this dagger here is on?
It shall not.
Well done.
I'll trade that.
That was pretty good.
Good job, guys.
That was good.